[Music]
i
am in front of the iconic fresh prince
of bel air
mansion it is for rent next month for 30
in honor of the 30th anniversary
the jaw-dropping 6.5 million 6
400 square foot mansion was featured in
the show open
i'll tell you how i became the prince of
a town called bel-air the exterior shots
and this scene of will giving dj
jazzy jeff the boot
[Applause]
[Music]
i know how jazzy jeff belt come on let's
get a look inside this thing
this is amazing i mean you walk in here
and it is
instant nostalgia you got the game table
you have the grand piano in here
this is where you will stay if you
rent the fresh prince of bel-air airbnb
there'll be five nights available for
two guests
you can hear carlton dancing upstairs
[Applause]
this wall right here the many sneakers
that he actually
wore on the show now we are in
the backyard now you might remember a
smaller courtyard
from the fresh prince that was on a
studio lot this
is the actual backyard will is kind of
an honorary hometown hero in bel air
only e.t was with him 30 years ago even
before the show's debut welcome to the
fresh prince bel-air tour 90.
it's a party going on right here
this is great i think i'm going to like
bel air another person who treasured her
time
in bel air will's on-screen little
cousin tatiana ali
and she spoke with kevin given exclusive
details about the much-anticipated
on-screen reunion